let's consider a collision in a lab
frame in which one particle is coming in
and the other particle is at rest so
here's particle to be to initial is zero
and we could say that m2 is twice N 1
and this is our lab frame and now let's
consider the same collision in the
center-of-mass frame and in that
reference frame we have particle 1
moving with velocity V 1 prime initial
and particle 2 moving with velocity V 2
initial prime now the way we're going to
analyze this problem is that we know the
speeds in the center-of-mass frame
relative to the lab frame so we actually
know these initial speeds and we'll
write that result down in a moment
because we know the initial speeds we
also know that the one final in the
center-of-mass frame is just minus the
initial velocity that's the beauty of
the center-of-mass frame the velocities
just changed direction they don't change
magnitude because we know this we can
get the 1 final and then it's just a
simple exercise to go back to the lab
frame to calculate the quantity the
velocity of object 1 in the lab frame so
that will be our sequence of ideas and
the key fact that we know is that v1
prime is equal initially to the reduced
mass divided by m1 times v1 2 where v1 -
initial
is just equal to v1 initial minus zero
so that's the one initial and the ratio
mu over m1 it's very simple to calculate
that that's just m2 over m1 plus m2 for
our case that's two thirds and so from
our result we now have very simply that
v1 final prime is minus v1 initial prime
so it's minus two-thirds v1 initial and
that's a very straightforward
calculation we can do exactly the same
thing with v2 final Prime the two final
prime is minus v2 the initial Prime and
v2 the initial prime is equal to minus
mu over m2 times v1 to initial this
ratio instead of being two thirds it's a
simple exercise that will be M 1 over M
1 plus M 2 is one-third v1 initial and
so we have solved for the final
velocities in the center of mass
reference frame now let's just
double-check our results we had v2 final
is minus v2 initial so that's minus but
there's another minus sign here so we
have two minus signs so that's a plus
and that's why we have the plus
one-third v1 initial and finally if we
want to ask the question what are the
velocities in the lab frame it's now a
very simple exercise to do reference
frame change we do need to know what the
center of
that's V 1 V initial over m1 plus m2
because remember that b2 initial is zero
so that's another factor d1 initial and
now for conclusion we have that the
final velocity in the lab frame is equal
to the velocity in the center-of-mass
frame plus V center of mass and we just
collect our results minus two-thirds v1
initial plus one-third v1 initial so
that's minus one-third v1 initial the
outgoing velocity of particle one in the
lab frame and the outgoing velocity of
particle two in the lab frame again we
have one-third v1 initial plus another
one-third v1 initial is equal to
two-thirds v1 initial so we were able to
solve this problem by switching
reference frame using our basic fact in
the center-of-mass frame that the speeds
remain the same but the direction
changes and enable to solve this problem
without any of the traditional ways of
applying the energy momentum
relationship and kinetic energy or
having quadratic equations